bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france emmanuel macron qui donc
dénonce un coup d'état inacceptable
annonce que l'union européenne allait
prendre des sanctions ciblées contre le
mali est ce que vous vous attendiez à
une réaction de la france à une telle
réaction de fermeté de la part du chef
de l'état ah oui oui mais je voudrais
juste quand même à rectifier dans
l'élément au sujet de cet après midi il
y en a annoncé officiellement qu'elle
est suspendue depuis le contexte du pays
donc ça tu es jeux pour wii ont la
situation en main
on s'attendait à ça de notamment des
présidents de la transition qui dit kiki
qui l'a mis au kiel a mis le président
et le rhume et les premiers ministres de
leurs prérogatives dont ce qui fait en
fait des fêtes tout simplement écartés
ne souhaitait la transition au mali etc
qui fait automatiquement
et effectivement qu'il fallait
s'attendre à la réaction de la
communauté nationale
je veux juste rappeler que la communauté
internationale était attaquée mais quand
même et c'est compréhensible si on peut
le dire comme ça avec avec le coup
d'état du 18 derniers et donc il n'y a
pas eu de sens de changer d mali
pratiquement il y ait de la pression
7 vous dit
a été concluant si vous comment vous
vous expliquer cette entre guillemets
indulgence de la part de la communauté
internationale
en 2020 la du tout quand même c'était
suite à à peu près quatre mois de
contestation à l'équipe pendant qu'elle
était pratiquement impraticable d'une
barricade de partout contre contre
l'ancien gouvernement ou à l'ancien
pouvoir des riverains boubacar keita
donc c'était presque une sorte de sortie
entre guillemets de sortie de crise
n'est ce pas qui paralysait le pays
depuis depuis tout depuis quatre mois et
donc et les matières qu'elles sont très
compliquées déjà au niveau de haut
niveau au niveau du nord mais mais aussi
les centres avec avec avec avec la
présence du groupe djihadiste mais aussi
quand vous savez il ya ya plus de 11000
à casques bleus qui sont présents mal et
pour la stabilité du pays et quelques
ils ont quelques milliers de soldats de
l'armée a clairement rappelé que c'est
bien elle qui tenait les rênes
est ce que on peut qualifier ça de
nouveau coup d'état selon vous ce sont
les termes que vous emporterez employés
riez techniquement oui techniquement
comme vous savez les pistes seulement
des termes juridiques
si vous vous rappelez ce terrier tant
que française les armées maliennes
mènent des opérations de lutte contre le
terrorisme et à chaque fois qu'il ya des
des hommes mondialistes n'est ce pas qui
sont morts si on dit et ils sont ce
qu'ils sont et alizée donc cédé moins
juridique en fait et donc le fait de
prononcer dans les communiqués qui
traitait mis hors délai au delà
hors de leurs prérogatives c'est tout
simplement une dernière question quelle
marge de manoeuvre
finalement pour le pouvoir de transition
au mali non ça va être très compliqué
parce que n'oubliez pas que la hantise
de ce jeune officier c'est ce pour
éviter un affrontement militaire comme
ce qui s'est passé en 2012 espère donc
ça c'est vraiment c'est la priorité des
priorités des militaires surtout pas
d'affrontement militaire malien ça c'est
la priorité des émois boris quand même
parce qu'il ya une mission de la cédéao
qui viennent et qui est venu cet après
midi à bamako qui a voulu rencontrer les
élèves les colonels mais malheureusement
ils n'ont pas puis ils ont la bouche et
les chemins parce qu'il est selon ce que
j'ai entendu à des manifestations
c'est la route donc ça risque d'être
très compliqué
probablement on va aller vers un embargo
delasau est il des choses se compliquent
on est allé il ya des possibilités et
des choses s'aggraver et 5 sont ciblés
mais comme j'ai on est encore haut débit
des quelque chose et j'espère qu'ils ne
vont pas merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france pour nous évoquer
cette situation au mali